first can you just give us your reaction
to the stabbings that we've seen in
reading of course they're fast moving
police investigation I'm good morning to
you and your guests I mean it I was
quite shocked to read these things and I
think I think what it reminds us is
although Corona is dominating the press
you know life still goes on I know that
the police are investigating it along do
we just need to wait to come back to see
if they say if it's terror or
unfortunately a murder let's see what
what's going on you mentioned a corona
virus there and I do want to ask you a
little bit about the rate of Kovarian
virus infections and in London because
if you look at the latest figures that
were published this week on Friday they
estimated the growth rate of infection
to be between minus 5 and plus 1 so
unlike anywhere else in the UK there is
a chance that a corona virus infections
are actually only up in London how
worried are you about that
of course I everyone I'm very worried
that by that but in London we have a
very unique situation in that there's 9
million people in one place and we all
travel around so far to work and of
course you have a great big corner of
emergency workers as well so we have a
lot of contact that made me slightly
smaller cities in the country wouldn't
have but I do see in London that people
have taken social distancing very
seriously definitely you say that people
taking social distancing seriously in
London but at the same time if you go
around London now you can't see a lot of
people out and about perhaps not always
obey associative distancing rules in the
way that they should have send the
outside pubs congregating in parks are
you worried that actually in some for
some people it feels like lockdown is
over in London I think there's two
things I'd say firstly on the whole we
have taken it very very seriously
remember is 9 million people in London
and I was queuing outside of our of our
supermarket which is adjacent to the
train station and saw very very few
people in their ridership on the whole
transport network is down very low the
other end of the argument of course is
that a lot of people whose families and
personal lives haven't been effective
but affected by coronavirus are
beginning to feel like they can start to
move around and we at that very strange
tipping point where we do want to do our
economy back
up and running so they're asking people
to move around safely and I think some
of that is what you're observing and do
you think we could see a spike in cases
after the black lives matter protests I
think we could see a spike in cases
anyway if you look at pandemics
historically there's always been a
second wave I believe we need to prepare
ourselves for a second wave but again we
still also need to look at how do we
start to get the country moving again
because one thing we know for sure
second wave or not our economy
absolutely needs to start moving as the
economy starts to get moving again as
you say more people going to work
spending money in businesses that really
need it transform it's going to be
absolutely key as well but now we've
been told not to use public transport
where we can but at the same time the
congestion charge has actually gone up
in London at a time when many people are
using their cars to try and say stay
safe is that right I actually don't
think it's right and for two main
reasons one is a mixed message there you
sayings people stay off public transport
but you're also saying to people they
can't use their car and why that's
important in London car use will only be
temporary but London is enormous and
some people don't have a choice they
can't walk or cycle somewhere and they
need to use that car and secondly
because the price has been bumped and
the scope has been widened so it now
runs late into the evening and on
Saturday in Sunday's it's affecting
people who are trying to run small
businesses people are trying to move
around to get their communities going if
they're religious etc and I think is
actually really quite devastating to
London like making a step back to
normality because really it's the
government that's to blame for that
isn't it and the I'm just looking at the
wording and the bailout deal the London
mayor said he kind had to sign up to in
order to get more money for Transport
for London the funding package is
conditional on the agreement from
Transport for London that it will agree
to the conditions below the immediate
reintroduction of the London congestion
charge and the ultra low emission zone
and urgently bring forward proposals to
widen escape and level of these charges
have you brought this up with Boris
Johnson I've brought up with Boris and
the mayor and what you find is the mayor
never gave any suggestions he just
marched ahead and why
the scope and increased the price and
say when you brought up with him he said
well that's a decision that mayor's made
and we're gonna have to go of it the
mayor is Mayor of London easy whatever
doesn't sound like a decision that the
mayor's made if the wording of the
bailout deal is that it's all that money
is conditional on the fact that he wrote
the money additional the money was
conditional on reinstitute reintroducing
the congestion charge that's correct and
it was always a temporary ban that I was
opposed
agent Lee bring forward proposals to
widen the scope and level of these
charges as well Sophie that's the point
he never bought full forward proposals
he just in state he just he just put
them on top you said right it's going to
be more money and we're going to run for
a longer period of time for a week never
asked he never debated with anyone and
that's the point isn't it Londoners are
not stupid we understand that the
economy's taking a hit we understand it
TfL need support but what we do need is
a mayor you deal straight with the
government so we can get the maximum
help going forward London's situation is
going to be tricky
but if you have a mayor who issues
failed to complete and has turned it
into a political fight with the
government Londoners will not get the
best deal that's why that's small but a
very important detail needs to be
focused on I'm keen to talk to you a bit
about black lives matter seen thousands
of people taken to the streets to demand
equality now Domenic rob was asked about
taking the knee he said he don't need
for the Queen and the missus when I
asked her to marry me and he went on to
say maybe it's got a broader history but
it seems to be taken from the game of
Thrones
it feels to me like a symbol of
subjugation and suborder weight
subordination rather than one of
liberation and emancipation were you
offended by what done that Rob said no
because I think taking the knee is a
very personal a very personal gesture
and you have to understand what it means
for you you saw some police officers do
it some not doing easy some people did
not do it the thing about taking the
knee it means nothing if you're bullied
into taking any it means nothing if your
boss sends you an email saying you have
to do it you do it because you want to
do it and you want to show you you want
to display what you believe that means
Dominic grant is in a very privileged
position where he could do many many
other far more meaningful things to
support the cause of you know of
equality for black people you don't
think it's a game of throne
cymbal well what I think it is it's a
it's as simple as it's definitely
symbolic and some people say okay where
did it come from what does it mean
but I'm very clear if you want to take
the Neal not is is one thing but what's
much more important is what you do in
your personal life I think where people
have missed something here we've talked
about the legislation we've talked about
the government but most of this is
hearts and minds and people have to
remember we need to do this together we
need to go together and I'm beginning to
worry that people are turning into
political football to suggest that
they're more interested in in the future
of black people and anybody else for
political gain gain so I think people
being truthful about how they feel on
what they're going to do is very very
important now you would be the first
black mayor of London if you get the job
but in a week where thousands of people
went on the black lives matter protests
there were reports that people from
within your own party were trying to
deselect you was that true actually I've
kind of dug around - but - what was
really good about this is was when this
rumor emerged I went straight to the PM
and I said what's going on here and he
said whatever issue and you need to
worry because I'm on your side let's do
some investigation certain people have
got big mouths and certain people were
always distressed that I was selected as
the candidate to run for the
Conservative Party but one of my
proudest boast is that I was selected by
the members the members had a choice and
they chose me and they've shown with
this rumor who they're supporting who
they don't support because they all
rally behind me and the most important
thing is the man that they suggested
wanted to do the job - he rang me
straightaway and he said Sean this is
nonsense I look forward to coming out
and campaigning with you so what I've
done is just taken solace from the fact
that I had more support now and I've
ever had before so I'm just gonna get on
with campaigning you said there about
some people with big mouths we've always
had a problem with your kind of a city
yeah why do you think they always have
had a problem with your kind of see look
anybody who knows anything about me
knows I'm not your typical politician I
was a youth worker for 20 years London a
born-and-bred I've been homeless I've
been raised by my single mother in a
council flat for some people this has
always been a problem but but for the
Conservative Party as it stands in
London that means they know the issues
that London faces
because it because they they've said it
they've they've set up opposition to me
but what it's done actually is given me
an opportunity to talk about why I'm
relevant to London is here in 2020 but
you'll always find in Ponte I mean your
your journey Sophie how much rumour
conjecture nonsense have you come across
in your professional career around
politics unfortunately it's the way it
goes but I really [ __ ] you you put your
head above the parapet you prepare
yourself for this kind of attack